l'agenda vous fait découvrir aujourd'hui
un plasticien du loiret un véritable
touche à tout qui revisite tout un tas
de techniques il s'appelle yann service
regardez
les orléanais ne le savent peut-être pas
mais un artiste a envahi les rues du
centre ville avec cet emblème présents
un peu partout j'ai la chance d'avoir
nombreuses oeuvres disséminées dans la
ville peu d'artistes peuvent se vanter
d'avoir la même chose les gens marchent
sur mes hall / amy
après avoir piétiné les oeuvres de jan
ervices on peut relever la tête pour les
observer un éventail de créations
retraçant le parcours de l'artiste
parcours qui a commencé il ya plus de
vingt ans par la marqueterie la pose de
plaquettes de bois de différentes
essences qui vont composer un portrait
par exemple un travail qui lui a ouvert
des portes dans le monde entier
d'ailleurs le jour où j'ai dit à mon
agent que j'arrêtais la marqueterie m'a
traité de fou et manu mais pourquoi tu
arrêtes je dis pas ce que je m'amuse
plus j'ai besoin d'aller voir ailleurs
donc j'ai inventé ma propre technique
j'ai jaugé nous détourner des techniques
liées à l'industrie chose comme ça pour
parvenir au résultat quoi y'en a galéré
il y en a donc commencé d'autres
compositions comme ses tableaux
mélangeant gravures et peintures ou
encore ses oeuvres avec différentes
couches de bois superposés d'un
plasticien souvent ils travaillent les
architectes ou des idées ou des usines
qui ensuite la création et sort à grande
échelle et c'est là ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en fait il fait
pratiquement des pièces uniques vous
avez 70 m en verre et en faire donc en
fait on peut le considérer comme un
artiste à part entière dans le sens
absence ou les pièces sont punis
un artiste qui se remet en cause
perpétuellement je rencontre des cd des
gens qui ont des savoirs faire différent
du mien donc je m'enrichis à leur
contact je découvre des choses comme la
découpe laser et donc je vais utiliser
ces techniques pour d'autres d'autres
gars je m'enrichis un artiste doit être
une éponge
une exposition à voir jusqu'au 21
février
des visuels un son à la fois rock et
électro voici les twilight motion ils
seront en concert samedi 7 février au
château d'eau à blois
comme tous les cons au pot aux roses a
commencé en répétant dans le garage
familial
aujourd'hui les vendômois se produisent
partout en france ils seront à l'intimé
festival de saint-avertin en indre et
loire le samedi 7 février
et pour finir une exposition qui en
impose au muséum d'histoire naturelle de
tours les mammouths fossiles et
reconstitution à découvrir jusqu en juin
la semaine prochaine l'agenda vous
parlera du festival numérique or les
anneaux ide et plus particulièrement de
l'un des artistes kantor